(audience applauds)
- Wow, I love this New York apartment
you moved into.
- I know, it's nice.
It's fabulous.
- It's great digs.
- I know, I love it.
I actually love being in
this building so much.
We're in the same building now.
- We're in the same building now.
See you in the elevator.
Listen, I've had a milkshake
burst in the elevator too.
You're not the only one.
- I dropped my matcha.
It went everywhere.
- Matcha.
Hey, listen, we've all
done a Jackson Pollock
in the building.
- [Kelly] No, it was my first day, man.
(Bowen laughs)
- [Bowen] It's beautiful art.
- It was also on the ceiling.
I think Andy, he caught it.
(Bowen laughs)
He was trying to be nice.
It was everywhere.
- [Bowen] That's okay.
- I've actually never had
a drink drop like that.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Did it drop or did it rocket to the sky?
- I swear to God, a ghost
was in the elevator.
I was holding it and then I wasn't.
- Right.
- And I was just standing there.
No one bumped me.
- Spooky.
It just was like,
"Welcome to the building."
- Yep.
- Like, yeah.
Yeah, so I trash things
when I enter buildings.
It's fine.
Have you ever had any mishaps here?
- Oh, definitely.
One time, for a dry mishap...
(audience laughs)
Rachel Maddow almost...
Rachel Maddow was trying to open
the door for me once, this glass door.
And then I kind of
leaned into it too much.
I could have broken through the glass
and killed us both and it would've been
a gay scandal in the building.
(Kelly laughs)
- This was a specific scandal.
- Specific scandal.